es scheint wirklich loszugehen
weltraumtourismus insgesamt drei
weltraumtouristen will allen masc
weltraum unternehmen spacex zur
internationalen raumstation iss bringen
und das schon im kommenden jahr doch es
wird für weltraumtouristen noch weiter
hinaus gehen kriegs um science fiction
die spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und activity glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen schon im kommenden jahr 2021
will ihnen musk raumfahrtunternehmen
spacex insgesamt drei touristen zur
internationalen raumstation iss bringen
das hat die texanische partnerfirma
axiom jetzt verkündet demnach soll die
reise ins all zusammen mit einem us
kommandanten in der raumkapsel von
spacex der crew dragon stattfinden
dieser professionell ausgebildete
astronaut hat die wichtige aufgabe die
drei touristen während ihres aufenthalts
im all zu begleiten und dafür zu sorgen
dass die csu trotz des besuchs weiter in
ihrer experimente und arbeiten
durchführen kann der aufenthalt auf da
es es soll acht tage dauern
hinzu kommen noch die beiden tage für an
und abreise
einer der drei plätze soll sogar bereits
gebucht worden seien dazu twittert der
ehemalige nasa-astronaut garrett reisman
aids on two thousand and just the start
of the whole new future of human space
flight sie will den flights starting in
1000 yuan doch weder sex noch das
texanische startup axiom machen angaben
dazu wie teuer der ausdruck für die drei
weltraumtouristen werden wird
schätzungen gehen aber von etwa 49
millionen euro pro sitzplatz aus klar
ist jedenfalls dass allein der start der
rakete etwa 55 millionen euro kostet
einen großen teil des geldes wird aktion
also wohl für den raketenflug an space 6
abgeben müssen doch auch die nasa wird
ihren teil bekommen erst im vergangenen
sommer wurde eine entsprechende
preisliste veröffentlicht jeder tourist
der auf der station übernachtet muss
demnach für den platz zum schlafen
wasser toilettennutzung und internet
35.000 dollar pro tag bezahlen
ich finde im vergleich zu einem nobel
hotel und im luxushotel hier auf der
erde gar nicht mal so teuer dass basics
hatte die crew decken für die nase
entwickelt damit die usa wieder in der
lage sind selbst astronautin astronauten
zur internationalen raumstation iss zu
bringen
zwischen april und juni sollen die
ersten mit der space ex kapsel staaten
mit dabei die beiden nasa-astronauten
bob bänken und doug hurley
die zwei sind sehr erfahren für beide
ist es der dritte ausflug ins all
dennoch handelt es sich bei der
bemannten space sechs missionen um eine
spannende premiere denn hier werden
astronauten der nasa zum ersten mal von
einem privaten anbieter zur iss gebracht
daran hat die nasa schon seit langer
zeit großes interesse denn seit dem ende
ihrer space shuttles ist sie aus
russland angewiesen um zur iss zu
gelangen dazu nasa chef jim brittens
sein
mit diesen kritischen test stehen wir
kurz davor selbst astronauten in
amerikanischen raumschiffen und mit
hilfe amerikanischer raketen von
amerikanischem boden aus zu starten
eigentlich sind die kapseln auch dafür
ausgelegt astronautinnen mehrmals ins
all zu bringen doch 26 möchte für jeden
flug eine neue crew zwecken haben heißt
also die anderen können dann für die
touristen genutzt werden und genau diese
mission soll in der zweiten jahreshälfte
2021 von florida aus gestartet werden
doch klar ist auch touristen auf der ss
gab es schon einige insgesamt acht
personen sind bereits mit der russischen
sojus-kapsel gereist ein us nummer
unternehmer hatte 2001 knapp 18
millionen euro für diesen urlaub im all
bezahlt doch laut axiom soll es diesmal
die zitat erste vollständig private
reise zur raumstation werden dazu der
ceo des start-ups michael suffredini
dieser geschichtsträchtige flug wird
einen wendepunkt auf dem weg zum
routinemäßigen zugang zum weltraum
darstellen dies wird nur die erste von
vielen missionen zur iss sein
die vollständig von axiom space besetzt
und verwaltet werden heißt also zum
ersten mal wird keine staatliche
raumfahrtbehörde an der mission
beteiligt sein und zufriedene ist in
fachkreisen kein unbekannter er hat
insgesamt zehn jahre lang ein ss
programm für die nasa geleitet und kurz
danach das unternehmen aktion gegründet
auf der webseite werden private mission
zur iss zwischen 10 und 180 tagen
angeboten alle dafür notwendigen
dienstleistungen werden von dem
unternehmen selbst durchgeführt auf
basics
selbst ist über diese zusammenarbeit
happy dazu heißt es vom präsidenten
klein shotwell in einer erklärung dankt
axiom und der unterstützung durch die
nasa werden privat besetzt die missionen
einen beispiellosen zugang zur
raumstation bieten um das fördert die
kommerzialisierung des weltraums trägt
dazu bei eine neue ära einzuleiten
übrigens spacex erst vor kurzem eine
weitere zusammenarbeit verkündet und
zwar mit dem us weltraumtourismus
anbieter space adventures zusammen
wollen die beiden unternehmen vier
touristen so weit ins all hinaus
befördern wie noch nie jemand zuvor
und zwar geht es um die dreifachen
distanz der erde 2 ss diese mission wird
für das jahr 2022 angepeilt
weltraumtourismus startet ein neues
zeitalter beginnt anklicken anschauen
und krieg zum science fiction abonnieren
bis dahin bleibt dran